Hello, Dr. Kevin Connors here again and we're going to be talking about the upper gastrointestinal cancers
We're talking about liver cancer, bile, duct, pancreatic cancer, esophageal,
glalbiter cancer. There's a lot of cancers that are tied to that and we could get much more specific
when you talk about different areas of cancers and just like all the cancers, these cancers are defined
by the primary area of origin plus they're defined by the primary cell type. So you could get a
esophageal cancer that is an adenocarcinoma because it really started in the glandular cells of
the cell wall or you could get a esophageal cancer that is squamous cell carcinoma in origin because
it started in the squamous cell which is literally the inner lining of the esophageus.
So there's different qualifications and classifications and naming of these different cancers but it
really has to do with the organ or and the cell type of origin. Now a metastasized cancer
remember is different so you could have cancer in your liver that's metastasized from the breast
breast cancer cells in the liver not the liver cells. So that's the difference. We're talking about
primary upper GI cancers in this section of the website. When we're diagnosed with cancer,
no matter what cancer it is, it tends to be a very scary thing. We tend to sometimes kind of lose
our minds and we want somebody to take responsibility and we get hurted down a pathway that we don't know
what to do and often we're not giving a lot of time to make a decision. My first recommendation to
everybody is to slow down and to think about it. Not that you shouldn't do standards of care but
slow down to think about it, pray about it so that you know exactly what you should do because you're
going to hear we've got to do chemotherapy or radiation or surgery or immunotherapy right away.
Understand, regardless of what you do choose to do, you could always add alternative care as well.
So even if you're going to go the standards of care out and use chemotherapy or radiation or
something like that, adding alternative care is always going to increase your success rate in the
end. It's going to increase the quality of your life as well. But then when you do choose to add
alternative things, you're searching for what to add and of course you're on our website here
listening to this video. So our job is to help you decide whether you're supposed to add
what specific supplements are, what specific herbs, what different nutraceutical type things,
what to do for diet. We want to take away the fuel sources. So something that you're eating currently
is fueling the cancer. The cancer has to feed off of something. So we want to test for what it's
specifically feeding off feeding off of and take you off of that thing. So you're not making drastic
dietary changes that aren't even in your best interest. Then what to use from a technology standpoint?
Of course, we're really big into the right for using the right. So we want to hold into those
frequencies and what those are. Ultimately, we want the best success for you. So that's what we're
going to look in for so that you have a very specific, unique protocol that's going to be best for
you to get the best results. That's what our hope is. No matter what you choose, know that we'll always
be praying for you. Thanks.